we have a fantastic cast right everybody
the whole conceit of that show um we're
talking about the rookie now we're done
everybody are we everybody back in the
rook now we're talking about the rookie
all right the whole conceit is that i'm
the old guy right so everybody there is
by nature of the story younger than me
there was a lot to potentially contend
with with a bunch of
younger actors but
we've got these
pros these people who just come to work
and they just know exactly what they're
doing
they find challenges in different ways
because
the job itself is not a challenge oh we
can make this work better if i switch
that would you like to say that line
instead that way it's not across the
room and you could just say to her and
that way people are solving problems all
the time they bring their a game every
day
the show can rest heavily on the
shoulders of any one of them at any time
do you have a smaller not a smaller part
you're the least yes you do yes i do so
you have scenes you're not in yeah a lot
of scenes that's it
this the the story branches out into
different adventures so yes by nature
every scene i'm not in that's an
afternoon i'd not work
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
because castle was every scene every day
every day you lost eight years of your
life
let's admit it
people you pay the devil in other words
people say so you're on a show you're
making money you're but you do sacrifice
i'm just letting everyone know that you
do sacrifice eight years of his life he
didn't have any time so those eight
years were gone yeah they were just
working now yeah again it's so it's it's
hard to complain because it's
complaining for you that's what
sure sure and there is sacrifice but
yeah i had friends call me up and say
hey are we okay and like i never heard
from you anymore
i don't have any time i don't have any
time
you